boys in indianapolis hey troy welcome to
the dave ramsey show what's up
hey dave thank you for taking my call
today
so to recap real quick back in december
just about a year ago is whenever i kind
of discovered you or rediscovered you
guys and
um needless to say i've drank the
kool-aid and
i listened to you every day read the
book and we're on the plan we started
our debt-free journey
my wife and i and our three little girls
good yeah and
during the covid uh i kind of lost my
position of the job i had for three
years
while i was contemplating looking for
other employment
and so i lost my position so now i'm
kind of down and pay a little bit when i
was making about 80
000 at the end of 2019 i went to making
about
45 000. so
we're but regardless we were able to
not borrow anything we cash flowed
everything uh cut up the credit cards
been making payments and been successful
and that means
great and two and a half months ago i
was blessed
with a new job opportunity and it's a
great job
great benefits good money
the only downfall is it's currently one
hour away
from our current house so the wife and i
have been talking that
possibly 10 months 12 months from now
that we might try to relocate in 2021
closer so my question is
is that when i looked the other day i
noticed during
the pandemic and trying to make ends
meet without borrowing any money that i
was
late on some payments with the credit
card companies and stuff like that
and it's really affecting my credit
score now i could really
care less what my credit score is but
i'm thinking
proactively if we do decide to go
shopping for a new home
and i know they look at that a lot is
that something i need to be worried
about
now yeah to try to absolutely okay
yeah what's the score uh when i looked
two days ago i think it fell to like
580. absolutely
yeah yeah you didn't miss one or two
payments you missed a bunch no no no it
was we were
we were just getting by because at the
same time
um a year and a half uh a year ago
i had a medical procedure and out of
pocket i had to pay
15 000 is what the total bill was so
we were really paying medical bills
credit card bills
a car payment our mortgage payment and i
went from an 80
000 income to down to about 45
50 000 so what's the new income
uh during my probationary right now just
salaried
i'm at 65 but it's a salary that pays me
time and a half when i go into overtime
so i'm fortunate on that here in about
three
four more months it'll take me up to 75
and then it will just go up uh two three
four thousand every year after that
and how much debt do you have now uh
right now when i did my debt snowball i
think it's calculated around 85 000.
yeah so you're not ready to buy in a
year troy yeah
he's right yeah just keep making the
drive yeah well or
sell it and rent yeah but you've got
you're not going to be out of debt in a
year no no no no
yeah i figured that but we were lucky
enough when we bought our home we got a
really great price on it and when i
talked to my realtor recently just to
get out of curiosity to see what it
would go for right now today's market
i'm calculating i have anywhere from 40
to 50 000
in equity in it now okay you may want to
go ahead and sell now
yeah go ahead and sell now and rent
yup and that gets rid of the commute and
those 40 grand that you're 85
and then let's clean up their other debt
and by the way as you're doing all of
this it's going to clean up your credit
yes because as you pay all i mean you
know
as there's two things that will heal
that number one
is obviously paying current bills on
time three things
number two was you start paying off the
debts
uh and then uh number three distance
between the bad
behavior and the day you're trying to do
something yeah so the older the bad
behavior is the less it counts against
you
it's still fairly fresh yeah but when i
looked at the report
i only had two or three months in this
year
on some of two different accounts
so i think one account i was late twice
on another one was like once on
but what i looked was is that five or
six years ago there's a series where i
was late at one point
and now it all looks like my total of
seven years i've been late
nine or ten times and i had five years
of on-time payments and it was i think
at one point at 7 20
yeah and that's that's exactly what so
you pay what you've got on time
yep uh you continue to reduce the debt i
personally hate a long commute so i'm
with
i would go ahead and sell now advance
the get out of debt plan
and rent and then uh once you're out of
debt and have your emergency fund then
you start talking about buying
still longer than a year this is the
dave ramsey show